let's go to the five five nine area code
who's calling today from five five nine
hey David it's it's Adam from Fresno can
you hear me yeah I can hear you fine at
him what's going on perfect so I was
wondering uh in relation to Bernie
Sanders is his Wall Street speculation
tax mm-hm
when I bring this up to other
conservatives about when it comes to
free college they say that that would
slow down the economy I'm not too sure
they're correct about that that sure
does are they saying a financial
transaction tax would slow the economy
or that free college would solve the
economy The Wall Street speculation tax
oh okay so the answer is basically no I
mean here's what you have to explain to
them Adam there are activities that are
economically stimulative and this would
be like for example you know a local
cobbler makes shoes and then the shoes
are sold and then there's a product and
the cobbler has to buy their leather
from someone else and then when people
buy the shoes they're now able to walk
to work where they make money right
there's this idea of like a stimulative
effect for the economy that part I'm
guessing make sense so a lot of these
speculative financial tools that exist
have been studied closely and they have
no positive stimulative effect on the
economy like just zero they literally
just generate money on paper which is
what money is but they generate money
from money in computers that is not
economically stimulative it's not money
that then is available for loans or
whatever it's just a process of self
enrichment and speculation so if you tax
that you're taxing an activity that is
of no economic value so it would not be
any disaster for the economy okay
perfect thank you okay yeah I keep that
in mind next time very good thank you
for the call
appreciate it great to hear from you